what's up guys bang-bang lunch money
bang bang
well wall she's trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get a lunch
money right coming to you every day
around noon noon ish we're recording in
at one o'clock so kind of missed that
bucket but we'll get our [ __ ] together
I've got the beautiful planet mera Nova
or today known as prisoner Polina
in her incarceration outfit what do we
got for topics coming out on Monday
well you know that stimulus package that
was supposed to be for small businesses
yes well a bunch of the money ran out
which if you remember I asked you last
week if the money could run out you
thought it was a stupid question but it
wasn't because when he did run out more
than a dozen publicly traded companies
actually got part of the money and they
have what is it they have more than ten
thousand employees and a lot of them are
public including Shake Shack potbelly
and a tex-mex restaurant chain all right
so first of all to clarify the record so
we don't have any fake news on here you
didn't ask me if the government's a PPP
program could run out you said can the
government remain money and the
government can't run out of money
unlimited liquidity but yes the PPP
program ran out on Thursday morning
around 10:30 a.m. less than two weeks
after they started 350 billion dollars
it was soaked up by all these businesses
only so estimations are three to five
percent of applications were accepted
and then they ran out of money so that
means that there's somewhere around 95
percent of small businesses that want
access to the money how are you defining
small business because obviously they
the way they define small businesses
doesn't quite work out
well again small businesses is what it's
intended for that still want access to
capital part of the issue is that they
have a distribution problem meaning that
the way that they're determining who
gets the money and who doesn't was just
first-come first-served so if you're a
local small business and the rules came
out on Thursday night of the week prior
well of course by the time you get your
application in these larger corporate
with big finance teams and lawyers and
accountants and all stuff they'd already
gotten applications it and so here's the
really really sad part one there's a lot
of people who don't deserve to get this
money or don't need the money
who are getting the money and then two
on top of that what's even worse is that
the people who are getting the money or
taking the money from somebody else so
that in essence they get it it's even
worse that if you take it from somebody
else and so now we've got Main Street
businesses that are not getting the help
they need but people like Shake Shack
Shake Shack it is incredible
I love Shake Shack on big shake Shack's
man dig Danny Meyer's a genius all this
stuff shake she has a 1.6 billion dollar
market cap company that's publicly
traded they did over 400 million dollars
in revenue last year they took ten
million dollars in the PPP program that
ten million dollars got taken from a
bunch of small businesses that didn't
get access to it a second data point
what do you think is the number one
geographic region on a per dollar basis
for what that receive PPP loans the
Northeast no Washington DC I sauce that
today Washington DC based businesses on
average received over $300,000 the rest
or the average across the country is
over 200,000 so they disproportionately
are getting more of the money seems
pretty interesting why would people who
operate in the backyard of politicians
be getting more money than others I
don't know I'm just here to ask the
questions you guys go find the answers
any last thoughts on big businesses well
Shake Shack actually gave back the 10
million dollar loan that received I feel
like that's an important thing to say
they did but why are they getting
congratulated know that you shouldn't be
my question is why did I even get it in
the first place well because when
there's free money available nobody's a
capitalist they out there literally all
become socials oh your give me free
money sure I'll take the free money well
it's a lot it it's a loan that doesn't
have to be repaid if you keep your
people on for a certain number so here's
what's gonna end up being here's what
it's gonna be really really sad is
they're all gonna keep their employees
until like September or October then
they're gonna fire them if this
continues right and then that brings me
one last thing I'm a big advocate assess
will include this in here Disney Disney
has lost their minds Bob Iger should be
ashamed of himself hold on hold on
Bob Iger or Bob see no Bob Iger because
Bob Iger went on for the last year and a
half went on this frickin back-patting
tour saying how great a leadership and
all this nonsense but when push came to
shove here's what Disney's doing
Disney announced over the weekend
they're gonna fire 100,000 employees
those 100,000 employees by getting rid
of them they will save 500 million
dollars a month that 500 million dollars
a month normally we just like oh look
they're not they're using parks aren't
open excessive revenues down of course
they can't sustain themselves but then
it came out that they're still prepared
to give their executives their bonus
plans so the executives aren't giving up
compensation but they are firing people
and then on top of that they have 1.5
billion dollar dividend that they're
expected to pay over the summer to
shareholders they're still gonna pay
that
and recently they went out and secured
over 20 billion dollars in lines of
credit that they could draw so if they
didn't pay their dividend they cut their
executive bonus plan and they pulled on
that 20 billion dollars of line of
credit they would be able to sustain
themselves for a year still paint all of
those employees it would have to lose a
single employee you don't know that
inner workings Disney like maybe there
was a reason they did that and not of
course something else because they
believe that the government's gonna take
care of it they're offloading their
responsibility onto the American
taxpayer why should we have to pay for
Disney when Disney has the money to pay
their employees right I don't know lots
of people will disagree but I'm just
saying I think again it is their right
it's really important it's their right
to do this because we are a capitalistic
society I'm not arguing that there
should be any change to their right what
I'm saying is it's bad leadership but
the right leader would say we're gonna
do whatever it takes to take care of our
employees we were gonna keep our
employees on payroll
and we're gonna make sure that we all
get through this together because we
believe if you're a Disney employee
you're a part of the Disney family and
family takes care of family have you
considered that maybe Bob C wanted to do
that but then Bob I the executor
Chairman came and said no no no where
are you a boxy fan I'm a bob season okay
what's the next thing
Eamonn Marcus Neiman Marcus isn't even
mark as a person no it's a great okay go
ahead Neiman Marcus is preparing to seek
bankruptcy protection as soon as this
week so you already so basically they
had a bunch of debt and they defaulted
yeah classic example if you get if you
don't have discipline you end up getting
screwed in bad times Neiman Marcus in
2013 I believe they were part of a six
billion dollar leveraged buyout by Harry
so this because I'm smart and I read the
internet because Ares and another group
did a six billion dollar leveraged
buyout there's about four point eight
billion dollars worth of debt hey Joe
make sure we cut that clip he's right
we'll just keep playing that on so how
could you possibly know the exact
numbers because I read the internet and
have a good memory and so on top of all
of that they're gonna have to file for
bankruptcy but my favorite part about
the Neiman Marcus story is they have so
much debt about four point eight billion
dollars that they're actually
negotiating with their creditors right
now to get a loan so that they have
enough capital on their balance sheet to
make it through bankruptcy
this essentially for those that don't
understand what's happening it's like
saying I'm in so much debt that I need
money so I'm gonna take out more debt on
top of it absolutely
but again all we're seeing is the virus
is having an impact on retail stores and
then you overlay that with the macro
trend like a commerce and I feel like
retail stores especially the ones with
physical locations where that was the
primary driver of revenue really
struggling right now because there's
zero foot traffic they were struggling
before but now it's like when was the
last time you went to a store and bought
something like inside of a physical
store yeah well not recently because I
did rent the runway because you were in
prison the runway because they delivered
to your home and you don't have to go
out and look at stuff in stores did you
get that off Rent the Runway no because
that's a pause right the runners
going anywhere except on the New York
Department of Corrections okay let's
speaking of Corrections let's talk about
drugs okay I can't deal with this today
okay um
Gilead I had to look up how to pronounce
it before this but Gilead has a drug
that's looking promising it's called I
don't know how to pronounce that rum
disappear yeah they had a clinical trial
trial and they're seeing rapid
recoveries and fever and respiratory
systems for people with Kovac so I mean
they don't they've only tested what 125
coronavirus infected patients who
participated 113 of them had severe
symptoms and then most patients
recovered in less than a week and two
died that's a 1.6 percent death rate
compared to the 4.9 percent overall us
rates like I'm not a doctor but I kind
of feel like we can run a test and
literally you could be like why made
these people drink water and these
people didn't and Oh drinking water
helps off cold Kovac or any
statistically significant well what if
some of them ended up not dying in some
did in the test work you just have the
point the point I'm getting at is like
yes I get that they did it for a hundred
25 patients but like if you're going to
get a drug approved and then go give it
to people or even worse mandate that
people take it you got to do way more
testing then don't kind of an initial
125 there was no control group so that
makes it tough yeah I think I think we
have a long way to go before we can say
something is really promising but but
it's all it's all so dangerous right
that people are talking about this as if
their medical experts and they don't
actually understand all the nuances of
the medical field of drug development
etc because then you get all kinds of
crazy theories and predictions and all
stuff that you guys should see like
sometimes when he's sick or like
something happens he has like a thing on
his eye I've never been sick yeah okay
and and I'll be like oh my god like this
old you know Bulgarians like remedy will
help and
like get out of here it won't help and
then it helps just saying she had me rub
a penny on my put my eyeball out all
right what's going on SpaceX like no
more drugs so on have one more for drugs
so apparently the cartels are scrambling
Isaac George oh yeah why the global drug
trade illegal drug trade is completely
you know devastated by coronavirus why
like because of their other
transportation shut down yeah and
borders are shut and get this ready
so the traffickers rely on like China
supply chain for the chemicals to make
really profitable drugs and one of their
main suppliers that shutdown is in Wuhan
wild well listen shout out to all my
drug dealers out there there are no
shout outs to your drug dealers no not
like my job well like all the people who
are drug dealers in the way well cuz
they're not tough economic time I feel
really bad for you guys that all of a
sudden your illegal activity is being
shut down by the virus I don't know
maybe don't break the law but I kind of
big business but I mean look here's the
opposite end of the argument is like
what's the difference between a drug
cartel and a pharmaceutical company like
the Sackler z-- I'm not gonna go there
but I'm just saying one of them just
happens to have the law on the right
side but you could make the argument
that the pharmaceutical companies are
actually killing more people that you
could because I'm here because other
epidemic is the opioid crisis exactly I
feel very strongly about this would you
know particular would you many go eyes
all drugs no I you what do you mean like
all drugs but just every drug is legal
now
no okay would you legalize marijuana no
no why why wouldn't it I think of this
done what's done marijuana why I don't
know you're regretting saying this
already I could say I just I see the
YouTube comments I think that they
should legalize marijuana for old people
for everybody if you could drink coffee
and alcohol
why can't you smoke weed because it's
different
why is it different it like messes with
your brain I mean what do you think
alcohol do I know we think coffee does
yeah you could take ibuprofen
all right guys new plan we're gonna get
plenty on the legalized marijuana train
leave a comment and explain to her why
she should do that what's going we got
six minutes
SpaceX um so NASA on Friday said a
launch date of May 27th for its first
now who can't speak mission from US soil
in nearly 10 years so basically they had
used to rely on the Russians to send
people to space except for in 2011 was
the last manned space trip from US soil
right oh yeah yeah yeah I need to read
that well I just taught it to you though
you said 10 years ago
go ahead so Elan musk with SpaceX is
going to send two people to the ISS in
Florida on May 27th Bobby that been
inked and Doug Hurley now here's the
thing as crazy these people are old dirt
right they're not old but they're 48 and
52 like you would think that most people
who are gonna get sent to space or like
young physically fit basically late
twenties early thirties no no but like
like the picture I think a lot of people
have an astronaut is not a late 40s or
early 50s person right and so I won
shoutout to being in physical condition
at late 40s early 50s to go to space
because it's incredibly taxing on your
body like all the g-forces and
everything but also you know oh we go in
10 G's let's go they were just going to
space like let me go yeah fast let me
tell you I read that on the internet
yeah but we'll figure it out but it's
fast it's always really taxing on the
body but to be able to do that at 48 and
52 years old like I feel like those do
like shout out to those dudes astronauts
are cool and guess what the capsule is
called
I don't know dragon the dress yeah I
mean if SpaceX is name of there oh okay
what last dance was going on last dance
so okay so last dance do you know what
that is that made her watch it last
night we watched the Michael Jordan
documentary last night um and I learned
all about Scottie P Scottie Pippen
Scottie Pippen we say Scottie Pippen and
so before this podcast are you high
right now did you smoke marijuana before
why are you laughing like this we
watched last dance last night it's a
fantastic documentary you haven't seen
it yet the first and second episode all
right guys I may be getting a new
co-host after this the first and second
episode was last was last night and then
there's episodes three three ten will
come out - every single Sunday for the
next couple of Sundays it's all about
Michael Jordan in the 90s and there's
only back twenty first century at the
NBA he's the greatest of all time don't
at me you can leave a comment if you
disagree but I'm not responding to you
because Michael Jordan is definitely the
greatest of all time yeah not even close
ain't no cite you know why cuz of this
you got six championships that's the
point of playing sports is to win he won
more than anybody else
championships no NASCAR well nobody went
he had a baseball career allegedly
because I don't know even called on a
career he basically spent a couple of
months trying to do batting practice and
it didn't go so well anyway I think
Scottie Pippen is why do you like
Scottie good because he's he's an
underrated underdog and everybody he's
not the underdog you was the second best
player in the NBA everyone because he's
dumb and he took a dumb basketball deal
he signed a deal for seven years and in
1990 and agreed only for 18 million
bucks and he should have gotten paid
more money but he signed a long-term
deal and also they told him not to sign
even though his own ownership was like
hey don't sign that deal they decided
anyway but can't you just renegotiate if
the owner will agree to it but the owner
said no that was this whole positioning
is we signed a deal that's the deal so
is the owner
basically the owners willing to lose
their best player because they don't
want to renegotiate their contract he
couldn't go anywhere oh why because he's
under contract oh wow
so he thought at one point he demanded a
trade so he can basically say I'm not
playing unless you trade me rusty could
try to force their hand but he can't go
sign with another team cos under
contract yeah that's how sports works
but does not feel badly got paid 18
million dollars in 1990 right now by the
way Jordan got paid like 20 million
bucks a year so he made a little bit
more am I am I the Michael Jordan or the
Scott Pippen of this video cast do you
want to know for sure you're Toni Kukoc
you know who that is huh Toni Kukoc
Kukoc yes the name of the players and
the balls in the 90s okay cool I'll look
him up wait till you know what part of
the documentary you're gonna love no
wait till we get to the Dennis Rodman
part oh the guy with the blond hair
I mean blonde was one of the colors of
his hair he also wore a wedding outfit
and he also is the guy who was in North
Korea and became wait yes Dennis Rodman
oh my god okay guys there's this amazing
documentary about Dennis Rodman it's
called the last day ask no Dennis
Rodman's friendship with thumb King Kim
Jong yes and they play basketball
together he's basically like promoting
world peace mmm do basketball and
friendship because he's kind to his
friends dead shaman said man he's
[ __ ] gangster all right lunch money
winners from last week there's three of
them I don't think that we pulled them
up cuz plaintiff didn't click on them
give us two seconds with our [ __ ]
together right now hold on a second
nobody mail is the one where says once
many winners those are the ones I picked
okay
I picked this week no I picked one you
pick one you did so the first one is
Nolan Royale the second one is Wow today
was a rough day guy so what are you
doing this one's my a great one this is
Cameron Archibald won one of the
subscriptions and his Twitter handle is
at I'm the tool I am th et
so go check him out what's the third one
hurry up okay this one I can't really
pronounce so it's at f CL r ly GP h TI c
we've DM do you respond give us your
email will get you the free
subscriptions to all three of you I
don't know why we pick three we said we
were going to pick two but we felt like
being kind we are now out of time
because you had a laughing attack I
think that you've got high during the
episode and I drink coffee that makes
you laugh alright you need to go back to
prison do you have any last words before
we end I don't but be well because your
friends that's it yeah all right guys
listen we appreciate it
lunch money while Wall Street's trying
to get rich thrust was just trying to
get our lunch money right tomorrow we
will come to you earlier hopefully
before noon and maybe we will get a
different co-host too doesn't erupt in
laughter in the middle of the episode so
thanks so much for watching we really
appreciate it and we will talk to you
guys tomorrow